hey guys I'm Jess I'm in and it is
Thursday see it's just one day from the
weekend how great is that
what's tomorrow for us eat that
first up Capcom has addressed whether or
not you'll see loot boxes in Monster
Hunter world you won't but they also had
more to say about that Monster Hunter
series producer Rios tsujimoto told
GameSpot I think that Monster Hunter has
already got that kind of randomized I
don't reward into the gameplay when you
call them monster after a hunt you don't
know what you're gonna get within a
certain range you've got certain rare
parts that you almost never get you've
got some of the ones you don't need that
you get a lot of and then there are
rewards for the quest as well there are
some rewards that are standard there are
some that are randomized and a bigger or
smaller chance of getting them he added
that Monster Hunter world doesn't need
that kind of system as it's already a
core gameplay aspect without you wanting
a microtransaction version of it in as
far as letting players use
microtransactions to get ahead faster in
the game the dev explained we want
people to have the experience that we've
made for them rather than the option to
skip the experience in news that should
surprise none of you super mario odyssey
is selling very very well you want a toy
no I'm known as for just how well it's
selling Nintendo announced that Odyssey
has become the fastest selling game on
switch and Super Mario game ever in both
the US and Europe topping 2 million
sales in its first three days worldwide
Odyssey sold 1.1 million units in its
first 5 days in the US which surpasses
the previous fastest selling Mario game
near Super Mario Brothers wait Nintendo
of Europe also claimed that Odyssey is
both the fastest selling Mario game and
switch game ever in the region Nintendo
also revealed that 2.6 million switch
units have been sold in the US as of the
end of October and the system is on pace
to sell 14 million units worldwide
between April of this year and March of
next year finally ending what is
certainly my favorite story of the day
Eleonora is coming to switch this month
and it doesn't fit on the console
seriously that's the story doesn't it a
little bit the Nintendo eShop version of
LAN wall and switch comes in at 29
gigabytes making it too big to fit on
your consoles internal memory so
basically you'll need to buy an SD card
to play it the switch is 32 gigabytes of
memory but six points
of that is reserved for use by the
system which is just really funny
according to Jack pretty funny if you
think that your best solution is just to
pick up the physical version guess what
that comes with a 14 gigabyte day1
update which includes required gameplay
data as well as general bug fixes and
improvements it's also apparently more
expensive than the digital versions I
guess because it doesn't require you to
go out and purchase an SD card meanwhile
Bethesda told Rolling Stone that dooms
upcoming switch port has a campaign and
in arcade mode that fit on a 16 gigabyte
cartridge although the multiplayer is a
separate 9 gigabyte download that is
everything we've got for you guys but do
let us know what you thought of today's
stories and remember we'll be back with
our Friday round up tomorrow so come
buying in there thanks now news that
should surprise none of you SuperMario
Odyssey is selling
[Laughter]